AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME
"EXPECTO PA-TROLL-'EM."
LAST WEEK, WE PLAYED THE HASHTAG
#NEWHARRYPOTTERBOOKS, AND A
WHOLE BUNCH OF TWEEN WIZARD
AFICIONADOS SOMEHOW BELIEVED
THAT IT WAS AN ACTUAL
ANNOUNCEMENT OF A NEW BOOK IN
THE SERIES.
AND PEOPLE WERE NOT HAPPY ABOUT
THAT LIKE @GINTARE_13 WHO SAID,
"LIKE WHOEVER MADE THIS IS NOT
FUNNY AND I HATE YOU.
#NEWHARRYPOTTERBOOKS." SORRY
ABOUT THAT
WE WERE JUST HAVING FUN WITH
STUFF.
WE HAD NO INTENTION OF CAUSING
UNREST IN THE SORCERER'S REALM.
I MYSELF AM A CARD-CARRYING
RAVENCLAW.
WE DIDN'T KNOW A LITTLE HASHTAG
FROM OUR SHOW WOULD CAUSE THE
ENTIRE INTERNET TO FREAK THE
(BLEEP) OUT.
SO SINCERELY, FROM THE BOTTOM OF
OUR HEARTS, WE WANNA SAY,
"HA, TROLLED YOU STUPID
HUFFLEPUFFS, HA HA HA."
WITH THAT IN MIND, COMEDIANS, I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO COME UP WITH
AS MANY INCENDIARY HASHTAGS AS
YOU CAN THAT WOULD CAUSE TWITTER
TO FLIP THE ( BLEEP ) OUT IF
THEY DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS A JOKE.
TOM LENNON.
>> #SANDLER IS THE NEW DOCTOR.
>> CHRIS: YOU ( BLEEP )!
SHOULD ( BLEEP ) CHOKE YOU FOR
THAT!
I SHOULD CHOKE YOU.
>> WIBBLY-WOBBLY,
TIMEY-WIMEY. YOU GET POINTS.
RON.
>> #TRUMP LENO 2016.
>> #ALL FEMALE STAR WARS.
>> #BLACKS WHO SUPPORT HULK
HOGAN.
>> #COSBY SHOW REUNION SPECIAL.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
RON.
>> #I STILL DON'T THINK COSBY
DID IT AND SOME OF THOSE LADIES
ARE DEAR FRIENDS OF MINE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> #TRUE DETECTIVE SEASON THREE
KIM AND CHLOE.
>> #DENTIST BAGS GRUMPY CAT.